-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Charlie Day.
The movie comes out
right before Valentine's Day.
Do you historically
enjoy Valentine's Day?
-No.
-Yeah.
-No, it's the worst.
First of all, okay,
if you're in a relationship,
there's an extraordinary amount
of pressure,
like, "Oh, I got to make sure
I do flowers,
get the perfect date."
Let's be honest.
It's a pain in the ass.
If you're not in a relationship,
it's just a slap in the face,
right?
It's just like everyone's out
there being happy and in love.
So it's the assface of holidays,
in my opinion.
-Yeah.
You've been with your beautiful
wife, Mary Elizabeth,
for a really long time.
Is there still an expectation
that you're going to deliver?
-Yeah, that's the problem.
You know, like, yeah.
And we keep doing it.
Even as a child,
I found it the worst.
Like, you know, you'd be in,
like, third grade,
and people would be
passing things,
and you'd get a little thing
and you'd be like,
"Okay, I got to open it."
And it says, "You have freckles
and are ugly."
Oh, what the --
You know, like --
-Yeah.
Just write it in a note.
Don't make it a machine.
-Don't make a whole --
Yeah, why do I have to
do the whole bit?
"5, 2, 4, 3.
You smell like farts."
It's no good.
-Very unkind.
-Very unkind. Even cruel.
-Kids are cruel.
We also had something in common
about our schooling days.
We both had parents
who were teachers.
Our moms were teachers
at the schools we went to.
-My mom taught music.
What'd your mom teach?
-French.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
How did you like it?
-I think it was sweet, you know,
when I was little,
in kindergarten.
Mommy's not too far away.
By like third grade,
I had lots of trips
to the principal's office,
courtesy of my mother.
-Really?
-Yeah, yeah.
-She sent you?
-I think she made
an example out of me,
which was like, you know, kids
like to goof off in music class.
So I'd be like coming in.
I'd sit down.
I'd make, like, a joke.
She'd be like, "You, gone!"
[ Laughter ]
You know, and the other kids
were like, "Whoa, man.
Mrs. Day means business."
-My mom was a pushover.
-Was she?
-I would get away with anything.
-How un-French.
-What?
[ Laughter ]
She's like [French accent]
"Oh, we cannot."
-[ French accent ] It's fine.
You can learn it.
You cannot learn it.
-[ French accent ]
You are children.
You are meant to misbehave.
-[ French accent ] They are
just exploring their humor.
-[ Normal voice ]
What was it like at the end --
when you went home on a night
where you'd been sent
to the principal
by your mom in the day?
-Totally fair, because she was
absolutely right to send me.
-Okay, got you.
-Yeah, yeah.
So you didn't
hold it against her.
-No, there was, like,
eye contact.
And be like, "Yeah, I get it."
-Yeah.
-"You did the right thing.
I get it. I get it.
Strong move, Mom."
-Alright, that's good.
You respected the game.
-I did. I did, yeah.
-Everybody says that about you.
-Yeah, I respect my mother.
[ Laughter ]
Class act.
-You have not been doing it
very long,
but it's already very popular.
You're doing a "Sunny" podcast.
And this is the cast
is rewatching episodes.
And so this is
a situation where,
obviously, you watched them
when you made them,
because you were a creator
of the show,
but going back
and watching them again,
do you remember everything,
or is there sort of a joy
of discovery going back?
-I don't remember anything.
And it's real sad.
Like, I think the other guys
remember everything,
and I think they're all
worried about me.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
But, no, it's good.
It's good to --
I sort of feel like
they all hold up.
I go in thinking they're
not going to be good.
Be like, "Oh, boy, here we go."
And I think the show
really holds up.
I'm proud of it.
-That's fantastic.
To do something like that
that holds up,
I mean, what more
can you ask for?
-That's the goal, you know?
-That's the goal.
-This is your first time
back in New York City
since this whole thing started.
-This is, yeah.
I've not been here.
I've not been invited.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Lorne?
-No.
-Lorne hasn't called?
-Lorne has not called.
He has not called.
But he will.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I'm keeping up hope.
Although, he's retiring?
-No.
-He's not going?
-I don't believe it.
-After 50?
-He says after 50,
he's going to retire.
-Okay.
-No.
-I think I could do it.
-You want to take over?
-I could take over.
-Yeah.
-I mean, when you
think about it --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you, thank you.
-Nobody's talking about you,
but when you think about it,
he's at whatever --
he's at like 47.
You guys are the next-
longest-running comedy show.
-Yeah, so we're basically
doing the same thing.
I could like...
-Oh, that's good.
-Now I got to do an impression.
Shoot.
I backed myself into a corner.
-Yeah, yeah, do it.
-[ As Lorne Michaels ]
He was funny.
That's about it.
Everyone does it.
-Can you do him
and De Niro talking?
-Oh, boy.
So it'd be like...
[ As Robert De Niro ]
You gonna put him on the show?
Put him back on the show?
[ As Lorne Michaels ]
Mm, no, Bobby.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-That was really good.
-[ Normal voice ] I didn't know
I was going to do that.
That was not a planned bit.
-I want to make it clear.
That was not discussed
ahead of time.
I fully put you on the spot.
And I want you to know,
that's me having a lot of
respect and confidence in you.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That was a foolish move.
-I wouldn't do that
to a lot of guests.
-Not a master impressionist.
'Cause I always sound like this,
and that's the problem.
-Well, that's the thing.
Everybody says you do
the best Charlie Day.
-Spot-on.
Spot-on. Yeah.
You know, I did have someone
stop me once in the airport,
and I think they heard me
talking and they came up to me
and they go, "Are you you?"
[ Laughter ]
And I thought about it.
I was like, "Am I me?"
I said, "You know, no, I'm just
not feeling like myself today."
And, yeah, but that was the
oddest one -- "Are you you?"
-I got one
my first year on "SNL,"
so, again, I wasn't well-known,
but I'm at a bar.
I was at a bar in Milwaukee,
and somebody came up to me
and said, "You look like
that guy on 'SNL.'"
And I said, "I am."
Because, again, I was new on TV.
I was so excited.
I said, "I am that guy
on 'SNL.'"
And he looked at me and went
"[Bleep] you."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah.
This [bleep] guy, man.
-"Don't go in the bar right now.
There's a [bleep] [bleep]"
-Yeah, seriously.
-"Trying to get me
to buy him a free drink
'cause he's new on 'SNL.'"
Well, thank you for being here.
-Oh, my pleasure.
You kicking me out?
-I don't want you to think of it
like that.
-Okay.
-It's just -- But yes.
-You got Sam here.
-We got Sam here.
We got other A-listers.
-I don't want to go
into Sam's time.
He's the best.
-Yeah, alright, good.
That's very big of you.
-Thanks for having me, man.
-It's great to have you.
-I'll see you on the beach?
-Charlie Day, everybody.